10 heures brahim alaoui son conseil sont
à l'heure pour l'entretien préalable au
licenciement sous la clameur de ses
collègues et camarades syndiqués après
plusieurs dizaines de minutes de
discussion les intentions d'un cm
nettoyage semble clair pour la cgt on a
demandé les motifs de
cette mise à pied puis de la possibilité
de licenciements dont qmi ont incité
certains points
déjà la totalité des points ne leur est
pas une mise à pied à titre ça c'est là
qu'on a vu on voit que on veut écarter
de salariés le cadre de l'entreprise et
tête de liste aux élections du conseil
social et économique d'assez m nettoyage
qui n'en possèdent pas encore alors que
c'est obligatoire pour lui son éviction
est en lien avec la création de cette
instance et sa volonté d'améliorer la
condition des salariés
moi je veux dire on lâche rien on va
continuer notre combat que ce soit
sûrement sujet au le sujet des autres
collègues parce que il y en a beaucoup
moi je parle de de connaissance de cause
et on a beaucoup de dossiers qui sont en
suspens mais on lâche rien on va
continuer le combat
braye masnaoui n'est donc pas le seul
salarié à avoir des problèmes avec 1 cm
nettoyage moi ça fait un an que jean
boucher ac et montbéliard et j'ai déjà
eu quatre erreurs de paye le mois
dernier 22 euros payés ou 200 euros
on a deux trois camarades qui mois
d'avril 11,0 sur nos fiches du
feuilleton dont le confinement famille
que les équipements du matériel au
travail 50 billets sont les chaussures
de sécurité
brahim hasnaoui doit quant à lui
attendre 48 heures pour connaître la
décision de la direction qui n'a pas
répondu à nos sollicitations
mais le dossier est loin d'être clos le
cadre est en effet un salarié protégé